uh no the u.s. what every visit the
dentist is like for me got large so yeah
but this is dentist um man I didn't
think that's what the dentist is gonna
be like in this world did you could even
like fuckin guess anything whoa what do
you first said like all the butter and
snakes I thought like it was a joke like
remember no like that's what his like
concept of it was like he was just
completely wrong about it but then they
have that X yeah dark yeah so so so fin
has a hurting tooth everyone says he had
to go not to the dentist you had to go
dentist and you know you really doesn't
want to so they finally say all right
you know just yeah just get ready for
like butter and snakes and stuff like
that and then you see like hung upside
down over this well where there's
nothing but butter and snake they're
like haha they just let him go and he
falls in and he goes into this world
advanced it dentist is this giant world
advance and they run it like a military
and the Queen is Lucy Lawless with her
New Zealand accent which it's nice that
she can use that yeah um and they have
to defeat the worms and the fly spies
and the only other cadet they have
really I think is Tiffany uh she he
comes back with if he he it was a he
okay uh I think in the back and like
they hate each other and he really wants
Finn sword keeps trying to double-cross
him to get it but eventually they work
together to defeat these worms because
they're under attack through some really
violent imagery how many decapitations
and like cuttings and stuff like that
were in this but because it's purple
blood I guess it's okay um and uh yeah
and then like Tiffany has a chance to
say Finn doesn't doesn't do it though
and Finn somehow get spat out and then
Tiffany knocked in and
queen worm jokes to death but they fix
Finn's teeth and then he climbs out
everyone seems happy uh but nobody can
talk about it because one of the fly
spies is going by and that's the episode
it was I thought this remind me a lot of
Ren and Stimpy like I can see like cuz
remember like their idea of like what
happened to the teeth is like there's
the tooth be from yeah nerve endings and
if you leave your teeth under the pillow
you get hundred-dollar bills from you
know the US the tooth old hairy man or
whatever and all I had was lint yeah he
just leaves a ball in air that's good
enough
it's just that bizarre and even the
animation uh you know stuff like Finn
being tossed up hitting his head on the
wall his body scrunching his teeth
cracking and so it seemed very Ren and
Stimpy to me yeah which is not bad um
it's definitely a little different not
extreme different but and even when
Tiffany was punching that looked very
kind of like Popeye to me did a you know
sort of the yeah you know all that stuff
um so it's God given the lineup of
adventure this might be one of the most
bizarre you just could not predict
anything that was going to happen in
this um I loved the ant what he's going
to the food line he's a good ending less
sugary I think he's like oh oh
or one oh the Queen in Finn goes in like
turns the chair around she's not there
she comes walking I'm sorry I wasn't
here sits down then turns back yeah wit
that jokes been done a couple times vey
a like an hour so I'll like no care Oh
Hawaii would have done well it's done
well in this fine be vet wife oh so uh
yeah it just it was it was so bizarre
but I loved how thin just like really
doesn't question much of it like they're
having the fight and it's just like Finn
are you okay my tooth hurts
just weird setup I mean he'll just kind
of go along with it you can't you can't
play mommy isn't such a
your world I mean why question anything
anymore um so it's they're gonna steal
banks yeah not a whole building they're
gonna not gonna rob banks she's gonna
rob banks let's get it the whole
building uh uh got you know someone like
for this one like it's either just like
one whacked-out writer or I just see
someone like let's just write the
weirdest fucking thing we can think of
like just like we have an episode just
called dentist like what's the last
thing nobody would ever think of what
happened in this episode and just go um
quiet
your mouth full of ants right now oh I I
did wonder if um uh you know cuz when he
feels he guy's teeth back you know he
goes hey like that I wonder if they
actually had to show that actor happy
days so that he knew how he was supposed
to say cuz that's supposed to be the
Fonz the way does you know any like that
okay with that Kingdom with that what
that kid know what happy days is or had
to say yeah like that all of those meant
to be happy days or not
oh my dad I use no thumbs okay
you can only also close up on the face
you could have gone like this yeah but I
guess the fun's those was like a did I'm
telling you always the thumbs no it was
never just his face but you couldn't
answer cause the buzz face ache I can't
believe we're arguing over this um no
I'm just I'm just thinking wrong I think
you're wrong
see yeah I think he never saw happy days
they showed him happy day so he would
say like the Fonz and it was amazing he
did it well with that with that voice
breaking sprite guy sound like every
Winkler age 90 Oh Harry Henry he's in
here nice it Henry
okay okay well clearly we're not talking
about the episode anymore so uh yeah
it's just I I really liked it I thought
it was fun I I thinking about the past
episodes of Tiffany and this one for
some reason when Tiffany's talking like
giving his speech and everything and
it's like poem it made me think of Linus
from the peanuts
that's the true meaning of dentist
Charlie Brown
kind of like the way that he's talking
and even almost the way his round head
is and everything for some reasons
episode made me just think of the
peanuts and I'm like why am i I don't
know but why it's clearly a kid doing
the voice um there's something I really
like when they give actual child actors
to voice children and it's a and I get
why they don't do it or they even rarely
show the actors suck
oh well it's some do oh but there's a oh
why you think the guy that plays Finn
sucks he's not a kid anymore I know but
when it started out he said it was
terrible really no um but there is like
I know what they do the voices change
and so on so forth now in something like
this or last airbender there they
welcome that they're like no please
change it'll be great we want the
characters to get older um but yeah
there's still something very unique to
the sound of a child that just you can
an adult like maybe a handful of adults
on earth can like really duplicate you
know where you swear it's a kid but yeah
there is just something very unique
about the delivery and the way a kid uh
this says Alliance I really like when
they get actual kid actors even if they
suck I mean it's like that peanuts are
not the best actor cuz let's be honest
you know whoever they get but there's
still kind of a charm to the way they
say it in such a bizarre mellowness yeah
that you know you kind of know it's like
there's no it strangely doesn't feel
manipulated it feels like no here's some
kids like putting on a play and they're
not faking it they're trying to put out
a good play they're just they're kids
you know you gotta get it I know the
peanuts or adventure tell on peanuts
know that the guys legitimately are good
actors that again oh yeah line is
getting up there and talking about God
and everything yeah that's completely
legit yeah that's how we okay what's all
this no that's a lot saying though like
with peanuts they would you know it
feels kinda like a school play where
with adventure ty they yeah that they're
part of the show it feels like they're
you know in that world um so yeah it was
um it was so strange but I I loved it I
I love anything right just I can't
predict it and it keeps throwing all the
strangeness at me and
I yeah I'll never go into the dentist
again no you're not going to go to the
dentist you're gonna go dentist yes when
we get to butter only if I get too
creative the snakes if you even like
snakes uh okay